[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend ihnen allen es gab Momente
in den letzten Wochen und Monaten da
wirkte die Hauptstadt der von Russland
angegriffenen Ukraine wie eine Oase des
kleinen Glücks Menschen sitzen in der
Sonne schlürfen Espresso mieten
E-Scooter Kiew ist wunderschön seine
Einwohner sind mutig und lebenslustig
zugleich die Mischung ist kaum zu
schlagen
dann heute früh die wohl größte
russische Angriffswelle auf die Stadt
seit Beginn des Krieges
und jetzt müssen sie wieder singen gegen
die Angst
[Musik]
sie müssen wieder kauern in der U-Bahn
gegen die Raketen
[Musik]
und Sie müssen bangen was noch kommen
mag
[Musik]
wir berichten heute abend ausführlich
und beginnen mit der Reportage mit
meiner Kollegin Alisa jung sie ist in
Kiew die ersten Sonnenstrahlen scheinen
durchs Fenster dann tut es einen
unfassbaren Schlag neben seinem Bett so
beginnt der Morgen von Valerie
twawkowski in Kiew
ich war noch im Halbschlaf ich habe gar
nicht verstanden was los ist und dann
habe ich das Glas aus dem Fenster
fliegen sehen und die Balkontür sprang
auf ich habe Feuer gerochen und dann
Rauch gesehen
seine Frau wurde in diesem Haus geboren
es hat die Bomben des Zweiten Weltkriegs
überlebt und auch diesmal hat die
Familie Glück die Rakete verfehlt sie
ganz knapp Sohn Dimitri fährt sofort zu
den Eltern versucht die Scheiben
notdürftig zu reparieren sie wohnen
direkt am chefchenko Park mitten im
Zentrum
die gibt es keine Militärbasis oder
militärische Ziele auch keine kritische
Infrastruktur in der Nähe das ist das
historische Stadtzentrum mit alten
Gebäuden uninteressant für den
russischen Feind sie wollten Zivilisten
treffen
sie will nicht wo eigentlich Kinder
spielen ist nun ein Krater Putins Krieg
ist zurück in der Hauptstadt er will
zeigen niemand ist sicher zieht auf
Menschen auf dem Weg zur Uni Arbeit oder
in die Schule doch in Kiew trotzen sie
sind kurz danach wieder auf den Straßen
ich war echt schockiert das hat mich
alles an den 24 Februar erinnert es hat
mir Angst gemacht weil es die letzten
vier Monate ruhig war in Kiew
ich gehe nirgendwo hin ich bleibe zu
Hause und bete für alle Menschen in der
Ukraine unsere Kämpfer für jeden und
jede
Bürgermeister Klitschko sagt im
ZDF-Interview russland habe mehr als 70
Raketen allein auf Kiew abgefeuert 40
konnten sie abfangen zu wenig um die
Sicherheit der Menschen zu garantieren
wir brauchen moderne Systeme das ist
gegen Raketen eher besonders in unserer
Stadt so das macht die Leben von unsere
Anwohner ist viel sicherer deswegen wir
brauchen Hilfe sie wollen sich nicht
unterkriegen lassen Räumen kurz nach den
Angriffen schon auf nichts hier soll an
den Tod erinnern sie wollen leben
bringen wir unsere Korrespondentin mit
dazu zunächst Katrin Eigendorf in Kiew
guten Abend katrin am Beginn einer Nacht
die ja deutlich sorgenvoller sein dürfte
als die davor wie will sich Kiew jetzt
Wappen wie kann sich Kiew überhaupt
Wappen
ja Christian du hast es ja vorhin
erwähnt also die Bürger der Hauptstadt
sind wirklich
unglaublich mutig und
widerstandsfähig aber diese Anschläge
die mitten ins Herz der Stadt getroffen
haben haben im Prinzip noch mal die
Verwundbarkeit des Landes klargemacht
wirklich wappnen kann sich Kiew gegen
diese Anschläge nicht sicherlich werden
wenn es neue Anschläge kommen diese
nicht so überraschend kommen wie wir sie
jetzt erlebt haben das heißt die
Menschen sind darauf vorbereitet dass
sie in die Schutzbunker gehen können
auch in die Metrostationen dass sie dort
Schutz finden können aber letztendlich
wird auch die Luftabwehr nicht
verhindern können dass hier weitere
Raketen einschlagen können das heißt ich
erlebe die Gesprächspartner mit denen
ich heute in Kontakt war doch als
relativ hilflos sind wieder die gleichen
Appelle an den Westen Waffen zu liefern
vor allem Unterstützung bei Luftabwehr
es ist wieder der gleiche Appell Druck
auf Russland auszuüben aber im Prinzip
bleibt die Ukraine doch sehr wunderbar
wie wir sie jetzt erleben gehen wir
weiter nach Moskau zu für begabt putinen
stellt das ganze heute als Vergeltung
dafür die Explosion auf der krim-brücke
wie sehr guckt er denn bei dem was er da
tut auch auf die eigenen Reihen
also es ist unwahrscheinlich schwierig
Putins engsten macht Zirkel zu
durchschauen und zu erkennen was da
wirklich vor sich geht aber klar ist
dass es da verschiedene Fraktionen gibt
und klar ist eben auch dass die Fraktion
zuletzt am lautesten war die die
Versorgungsengpässe und auch die
Planlosigkeit beim russischen Militär
kritisiert hat diese Leute die haben die
Angriffe heute
begrüßt teilweise sogar bejubelt da ist
unter anderem der tschetschenische
Anführer ramsam kadirov der sagte er sei
zu 100 Prozent zufrieden oder auch der
Chef der annektierten Halbinsel Krim der
sagte er habe schon seit Februar dafür
plädiert dass die Ukraine eben genau so
stark unter Beschuss genommen werde wie
das heute der Fall war also durch diese
Bombardements durch diese Raketen
Angriffe hat Putin die Hardliner in
seine Umfeld besänftigt und das bevor
die Kritik an der Militärführung auf den
Oberbefehlshaber also auf ihn selbst
weil die mir Putin überschwappen konnte
zumindest für den Moment und wenn das
irgendwann nicht mehr reicht auch dafür
wurde heute rhetorisch vorgesorgt
denn da wurde ja auch gesagt dann könne
man jederzeit noch weiter eskalieren
und Katrin ganz herzlichen Dank für
diese Analyse heute abend es war heute
nicht nur kiew-ziel der Angriffe in der
gesamten Ukraine holten die Sirenen
neben zivilen Zielen und dem Bemühen
Panik zu schüren scheint insbesondere
die Energieinfrastruktur im Fadenkreuz
der russischen Raketen zu stehen und
dann tut sich eine neue alte unheilvolle
Allianz auf Lara Wiedeking hat die
Details
Lemberg am Morgen auch ganz im Westen
der Ukraine schlagen russische Raketen
ein es gibt keinen Strom kein warmes
Wasser bisher galt Lemberg als
vergleichsweise sicher
die Raketenangriffe im ganzen Land seien
die Antwort auf die Explosion auf der
Brücke die auf die von Russland
annektierte Krim führt die russische
Propaganda spricht von Vergeltung für
ukrainischen Terror
sollte es weiter Versuche geben
Terroranschläge auf unserem Gebiet
durchzuführen wird Russlands Antwort
hart und angemessen je nach
Bedrohungslage für die Russische
Föderation
daran sollte niemand Zweifel haben
getroffen wurden neben Lemberg auch
nikolajev im Süden nipro und rakif
weiter im Osten und auch saporisha
Präsident selenski bittet die Menschen
Schutz zu suchen
es ist ein harter morgen wir haben es
mit Terrorismus zu tun denkt immer daran
die Ukraine gab es bevor dieser Feind
erschien und sie wird auch danach noch
existieren
einige der Angriffe seien auch vom
benachbarten Belarus gestartet so die
ukrainische Armee dort verschärft
Machthaber Lukaschenko ein enger
Verbündeter Putins das großszenario
sagt dem ukrainischen Präsidenten und
den anderen Verrückten sollten Sie
jemals einen Quadratmeter unseres
Territoriums mit ihren dreckigen Händen
berühren wird die krim-brücke wie ein
Spaziergang wirken
Lukaschenko erklärte außerdem man sei
bereits dabei gemeinsam mit Russland
eine militärische Eingreiftruppe zu
bilden
so und darüber wollten wir jetzt
eigentlich sprechen mit einem Russland
Experten der Uni Innsbruck das versuchen
wir gleich in dieser Sendung noch
nachzuholen was hoffentlich besser
klappt ist nachher im heute schon mal
Update Fragen von Gundula Gause an den
ehemaligen General Hans Lothar Domröse
das nachher und in Deutschland da gucken
wir jetzt zwischendurch hin da raucht
einem der kopfumlage Bremse Deckel es
ist nicht ganz einfach da noch
durchzusteigen was konkret der Staat tun
wird um seinen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
die explodierten Energiepreise
abzufedern jetzt hat eine
Expertenkommission getagt 35 Stunden
noch mal am Wochenende ein schriftlichen
Vorschlag vorgelegt und damit wird
klarer was konkret geplant ist eine
Einmalzahlung im Dezember und dann Preis
bremsen ab März
das soll entschlossen klingen dieser Tag
zeigt aber auch so ein gewaltiger
staatlicher Eingriff in die Preise ist
immer sehr riskant und sehr teuer Karl
Hinterleitner
Gummi für Schläuche Scheibenwischer und
Dichtungen seit fast 30 Jahren
produziert der mittelständische
Familienbetrieb die guma im
thüringischen Geisa die Chefin ist
besorgt angesichts der Explosion der
Energiepreise fürchtet sie um die
Zukunft Ihres Unternehmens
da keine Möglichkeit an Polster
aufzubauen um Gegenteil unsere Polster
wurden massiv abgebaut und deswegen
müssen wir wirklich jeden Monat aufs
neue gucken wie wir mit bestimmten
Sachen umgehen zum Beispiel den
Preissteigerungen und in Berlin ging es
heute darum wie man die am besten
abfängt mit 96 Milliarden Euro die
gaskommission präsentierte ihre
Vorschläge in einem ersten Schritt soll
der Staat im Dezember den Abschlag für
private Haushalte zahlen
schlagzahlung entlastet das ist ein sehr
pragmatisches Vorgehen um erstmal die
Kostenbelastung für die Menschen zu
dämpfen ab März kommenden Jahres soll
dann die sogenannte gaspreisbremse
greifen für 80 Prozent eines geschätzten
grundverbrauchs werden die Preise auf 12
Cent pro Kilowattstunde abgesenkt
oberhalb dieser Menge fällt der deutlich
höhere Marktpreis an Laufzeit der Bremse
erst einmal bis Frühjahr 2024 zu wenig
und zu spät meinen Kritiker die
Erstattung einer einzigen monatlichen
Abschlagszahlung für Dezember für die
kommenden fünf Monate heißt eine
Entlastung von 20 Prozent bei Gaspreisen
die sich für drei vervierfach fünffacht
haben und die dauerhafte Hilfe ab März
nächsten Jahres kommt eben für viele zu
spät ein weiteres Problem jeder Kunde
bekommt die Einmalzahlung und auch der
preisdeckel ist für alle gleich
unabhängig von Wohnlage und sozialer
Situation Vertreter der Gewerkschaften
sowohl selbstmitglied der gaskommission
findet das ungerecht also das nach dem
Vorschlag der Energiepreis gedeckelt
subventioniert wird und zwar unabhängig
davon wie hoch der Verbrauch ist das
heißt der Verbrauch für eine
Zweizimmerwohnung wird genauso
subventioniert wie für eine Villa mit
Pool und das ist eine soziale Schieflage
die versucht werden muss im weiteren
Verfahren zu korrigieren dennoch sei die
Empfehlung der gaskommission insgesamt
richtig denn das habe ich jetzt vor
allem schnell gehen müssen wir wollten
in der Entwicklung des Modells und in
der Entlastungswirkung schnell sein und
es sollte spätestens zum Jahresende
diesen Jahres eine erste
Entlastungsmöglichkeit geschaffen werden
die Industrie bekommt keinen
dezemberabschlag dafür einen preisdeckel
von 70 Prozent ab Januar
zugleich ja wir haben gerungen aber wir
haben ein Ergebnis erreicht dass wir für
belastbar halten und auf dieses Ergebnis
kann die Bundesregierung jetzt aufsetzen
die muss über die Vorschläge nun
entscheiden möglichst schnell den Firmen
wie der die guma geht es zwar noch gut
aber sie und andere brauchen bezahlbare
Energie um den kommenden Winter zu
überstehen
und wir bleiben noch beim Dauerthema Gas
damit beginnst du jetzt deinen
nachrichtenüberblickkanal und da blicken
wir auf die Explosionen an den
nordstream Pipelines in der Ostsee in
dieser Sache ermittelt nämlich jetzt die
Bundesanwaltschaft es handelt sich um
einen schweren gewalttätigen Angriff auf
die energiewirtschaftliche Versorgung
die geeignet sei die äußere und innere
Sicherheit Deutschlands zu
beeinträchtigen erklärte die Behörde
Ende September waren insgesamt vier Lex
an den beiden nordstream Pipelines
entdeckt worden tagelang traten große
Mengen Gas aus
die UN-Vollversammlung berät seit fast
einer Stunde in einer
Dringlichkeitssitzung über die
völkerrechtswidrige Annexion von
mehreren Teilen der Ukraine durch
Russland am Ende der Debatte soll über
eine Resolution abgestimmt werden die
das russische Vorgehen verurteilt dabei
wird eine breite Zustimmung erwartet die
Resolution ist allerdings
völkerrechtlich nicht bindend
Großbritannien hat wegen schwerer
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Sanktionen
gegen die iranische Sittenpolizei und
führende Politiker und Sicherheitsbeamte
verhängt diese dürfen nicht mehr nach
Großbritannien einreisen und
Vermögenswerte im Vereinigten Königreich
werden eingefroren die EU arbeitet noch
an möglichen Sanktionen diese könnten
beim Außenminister Treffen in der
kommenden Woche verabschiedet werden
unter dessen gingen die regimekritischen
Proteste in Iran auch heute weiter unter
anderem in Teheran und im Kurdengebiet
im Westen des Landes
bis Ende des Jahrhunderts könnten
extreme Hitzewellen ähnlich viele Tote
fordern wie infektions- und
Krebserkrankungen das ist die
eindringliche Warnung eines Berichts von
un- und Rotem Kreuz die Experten fordern
weltweit eine bessere Vorbereitung auf
Hitzeperioden zum Beispiel durch
Warnsysteme und die Finanzierung von
kühlen öffentlichen Räumen in besonders
betroffenen Regionen
Hitzewellen könnten Gebiete wie die
Sahelzone das Horn von Afrika sowie Süd-
und Südwestasien unbewohnbar machen wenn
der Klimawandel nicht gestoppt werde
wenn drei Parteien ein Team bilden und
dann kommen zwei Parteien dabei deutlich
besser weg als die dritte was heißt das
für die künftige Zusammenarbeit
kann sich jeder denken wenn die
Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen gestern
auch sowas war wie ein Zwischenzeugnis
für die Berliner ampelregierung und
selten zuvor waren bundespolitische
Themen in einem regionalen Wahlkampf so
präsent dann dürfen sich am Ende zwei
als Gewinner fühlen und einer hat
verloren das wiederum heißt aber auch
für die Gewinner dass sie es in Zukunft
mit dem Dritten im Bunde deutlich
schwerer haben dürften Ines Trumps
berichtet
die Ampel im Bund bringt ihnen kein
Glück so viel scheint klar drei
Landtagswahlen verloren nun fliegen die
Liberalen aus dem niedersächsischen
Landtag doch Parteichef Lindner betont
selbstbewusst ihre Linie sei richtig sie
müssten sie künftig nur stärker
herausstellen die große Frage ist wie
wir diese Liberalen Grund Überzeugungen
innerhalb einer Bundesregierung und
innerhalb der notwendigen Krisenpolitik
für die Wählerinnen und Wähler so
erkennbar machen also wie wir die
Positionslichter der FDP anschalten
damit man sieht das ist genau die Partei
die ich eigentlich will deutlicher
werden liberale die nicht in der
Verantwortung stehen da heißt es
beispielsweise mir blutet das Herz die
Ampelkoalition ist politische
Vergewaltigung der FDP die Nerven liegen
blank am Abend der Wahl eine emotionale
Drohung an Rot und Grün eine Koalition
wird nicht funktionieren wenn zwei
Partner permanent Ideen entwickeln wie
man noch mehr Geld und noch mehr Geld
ausgeben und andere sich permanent mit
der Frage beschäftigen müssen wie man
das Ganze organisiert und finanziert die
Grünen haben Daumen gedrückt das ist die
FDP in den landtagschaft so groß die
Sorge vor einer profilierungswütigen FDP
im Bund gesprächsbereit zeigt sich nun
der Grünen Chef allerdings nicht bei den
AKW-Laufzeiten wenn die
fdp-beratungsbedarf hat wir sind bereits
wir sind wir sind zu für alle Gespräche
jeglicher Art stehen wir zur Verfügung
und wenn Sie der Meinung sind dass man
bestimmte Dinge nachjustieren muss dann
müssen wir darüber reden Lob und Blumen
für den Gewinner der Wahl Stefan weil
auch vom Kanzler obwohl weil er trotz
Olaf Scholz die Mehrheit in
Niedersachsen holte der
SPD-Parteichef mahnt zur Einigkeit unter
den ampelpartnern erst recht nach dieser
Wahl die Antwort darauf ist nicht
dass wir uns behaken sondern die Antwort
ist dass wir uns unterhaken eine
testabstimmung gegen die Ampel war das
Ziel der CDU heute spricht der
Parteichef von einer Regionalwahl ein
unklares Profil das zwischen Frauenquote
und Aussagen zur Migration schwankt will
er nicht als Ursache erkennen für das
schlechte Abschneiden in Niedersachsen
wir haben diese Landtagswahl nicht zu
einer Volksabstimmung über die
Bundesregierung gemacht und auch nicht
machen können und insofern ist das
Wahlergebnis in erster Linie ein
Wahlergebnis der Landespolitik 50.000
Wähler hat die CDU allein an die AFD
verloren die ihr Ergebnis in Hannover
fast verdoppelt anders als die
Linkspartei profitiert sie von den
Ängsten der Menschen vor den Folgen des
Krieges
insgesamt haben wir auch gesehen dass
wir jetzt natürlich diese Wähler die wir
gewonnen haben eben nicht nur aus dem
Protestlager gewonnen haben sondern dass
wir mit Überzeugung aus FDP und CDU
Wähler zu uns rübergezogen haben dass
wir die natürlich erstammwähler gewinnen
wollen Empfang für den ungarischen
Ministerpräsidenten business as usual
doch klar ist es wird schwieriger für
Scholz die Ampel zusammenzuhalten
angesichts einer hoch nervösen FDP
und hier jetzt noch mal Johanna ja und
zwar mit einem prominent besetzten
Treffen mit Punkten auf der Tagesordnung
die es in sich haben in Washington hat
heute die Jahrestagung von Weltbank und
Internationalen Währungsfonds begonnen
es geht unter anderem um die hohe
Inflation und die schwierige Situation
von Entwicklungsländern Sina Malitz in
Frankfurt was kann dieses Treffen
bringen ja also es zeichnet sich ja
tatsächlich immer mehr eine globale
Rezession ab und bei diesem Treffen von
Internationalem Währungsfonds und
Weltbank geht es eben darum diese
Abwärtsspirale möglichst aufzuhalten
darüber beraten nun Wirtschaftsexperten
Banker Finanzminister und Notenbankchefs
morgen dann veröffentlicht der
Internationale Währungsfonds seine
jüngste Prognose zur Lage der
Weltwirtschaft und zuletzt war es ja so
dass jeder Ausblick noch düsterer war
als der vorangegangene wenig
verwunderlich denn die drei wichtigsten
Volkswirtschaften der Welt sind in der
Krise die Eurozone leidet unter hohen
Energiepreisen China kämpft weiterhin
mit corona-pandemie und die USA
Schwächen die Konjunktur durch eine
strikte Zinspolitik im Kampf gegen die
Inflation so sagt die IWF-Chefin
kristalliner Georgieva in den
vergangenen drei Jahren haben wir
unvorstellbare Ereignisse erlebt die
erhebliche Folgen haben kovet ist immer
noch bei uns der Einmarsch Russlands in
die Ukraine hat überall dramatische
Folgen auch Klimakatastrophen auf allen
Kontinenten hätten die Menschen in
schwierige Situationen gebracht so
werden einen Schuldenschnitt für ärmere
Länder eine vorsichtige Finanzpolitik
reicher Länder und Stützungsmaßnahmen an
den Börsen ins Spiel gebracht apropos
Börse die Frankfurter Börse zeigt sich
heute unverändert bei plusminus Null und
einem DAX Stand von
12.273 Punkten die Hoffnung auf einen
kraftvollen Wochenstart am Aktienmarkt
war auch heute schnell wieder dahin
vielen Dank Sina nach Frankfurt
in Stockholm wurden heute wurde heute
der Wirtschaftsnobelpreis verliehen er
geht an drei US-Ökonomen ausgezeichnet
wurden der ehemalige
US-Notenbankchef Ben bernenkey sowie
Douglas Diamond und Philip dipwig ihre
Erkenntnisse über das Bankensystem
hätten die Fähigkeit verbessert sowohl
schwere Finanzkrisen als auch teure
Rettungsaktionen zu vermeiden so die
Begründung der Jury
in Venezuela sind bei einem Erdrutsch
mindestens 22 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen mehr als 50 werden noch
vermisst betroffen ist die stadtlast
Terriers südwestlich der Hauptstadt
Karakas Hurricane julia hatte zuvor
durch schwere Regenfälle mehrere Flüsse
zum Überlaufen gebracht die Wassermassen
lösten Felsen und Bäume von den Hängen
und rissen Autos mit sich Präsident
Maduro rief eine dreitägige Staatstrauer
aus
und noch eine Meldung vom Sport
Fußball-Bundesligist VfB Stuttgart hat
sich heute nach fast drei Jahren von
Trainer Pellegrino matarazzo getrennt
Grund ist die bisher er nüchternde
Bilanz in dieser Bundesliga-Saison nach
neuen Spielen ohne Sieg rangiert der VfB
Stuttgart aktuell auf dem vorletzten
Tabellenplatz
2021 hatte matarazzo die Stuttgarter
zurück in die erste Liga geführt
ja und wenn Sie jetzt einen vertiefendes
Gespräch vermissen zur Lage in der
Ukraine nach der verheerenden russischen
Angriffswelle heute früh wir tun es auch
wir waren fest verabredet mit einem
Wissenschaftler an der Uni Innsbruck
dessen Fachgebiet Spezialgebiet
Sicherheit im postserviertischen Raum
ist das hätte also geklappt nur leider
hat die Leitung nicht funktioniert da
gibt es offensichtlich massive Probleme
von hier in Mainz ins schöne Innsbruck
und deswegen war das die Welt da diesen
Montag im heute journal für diesen Tag
danke für Ihr Interesse wir wünschen
Ihnen noch einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt liegt hier die
Kaltfront von tief Bettina einmal quer
der Länge nach über Deutschland sie
trennt das hochvangiles von dem nächsten
hoch Wim und kräftige Regenschauer und
Gewitter gibt es hier am Mittelmeer das
Mittelmeer übrigens hat derzeit noch
sehr hohe Temperaturen an der Cote
d'Azur sind es nur so 18 Grad aber im
südlichen Mittelmeer finden Sie noch
Wassertemperaturen von 27 28 Grad da
gibt es dann eben kräftige Gewitter und
Gewitter gibt es heute Nacht auch bei
uns hier in Süddeutschland da sind doch
einige Regenschauer unterwegs die kalt
von von tief Bettina wird aber schon in
der zweiten Nachthälfte hier die
Ostseeküste erreichen dahinter lockern
die Wolken auf dann bildet sich Nebel
und dann sinken die Temperaturen auf
fünf bis zwei Grad im Südwesten bleibt
es deutlich milder bei 12 bis 9 Grad
sonst sind es so 9 bis 6 Grad und morgen
liegen die Temperaturen in den östlichen
genauso wie in den westlichen
Mittelgebirgen nur so bei 12 13 Grad
bilder wird es dagegen am Hochrhein oder
auch am Bodensee mit 19 vielleicht sogar
mal 20 Grad
morgen Vormittag wird es in
Norddeutschland häufig Sonnenschein
geben dann gibt es immer mehr quellwolke
und hier und da am Nachmittag auch
eineige Regenschauer bei West
Nordwestwind in der Mitte Deutschlands
aber kann sich nach Nebel häufig die
Sonne zeigen in Süddeutschland hält die
kalt von am längsten durch da gibt es
auch noch weitere Regenfälle der
Mittwoch bringt uns dann goldenes
Oktoberwetter Donnerstag und Freitag
werden wieder etwas wechselhafter
besonders im Süden und im Westen
Deutschlands guten Abend